one day they meditated
saying it would be exceedingly helpful
to us if we were to leave this region
and set out for the west for we then
could visit the tombs of the holy
martyrs
and catholic fathers and be blessed by
them
and if christ the lord of the universe
prolonged our lives
and sustained us by his grace we could
go to jerusalem
so that we might receive complete pardon
for our offenses
and absolution for our sins of
foolishness
they rose up and distributed their
furniture and the objects which they
used in everyday life
among the poor and they went to that
city so that they might take
companions for the journey and provide
themselves
with food for the way
[Music]
and rabban salma set out on his journey
and there went with him a number of
excellent men from among the priests and
deacons of the cell of the catholicus
and he arrived at beth romay on the
borders of the sea
of mecca
he saw the church that was there and
then went down in a ship
and his companions were with him now
there were more than 300 souls in the
ship
and each day he consoled them with his
discourse on the faith
now the greater of those who dwelt in
the ship were romans
and because of the savour of his speech
they paid him honor
in no small degree and after some days
he arrived in the great city
of constantinople and before they went
in
he sent two young men to the royal gate
to make known
that an ambassador of king argonne had
come
then the king commanded certain people
to go forth and meet them
and to bring them in with pomp and honor
and when robin salma went into the city
the king allotted him a house and after
raban salma had rested himself
he went to visit the king andronicus ii
and after he had saluted him the king
asked him
how art thou after the workings of the
sea and the fatigue of the road
and rabban salma replied with the sight
of the christian king
fatigue hath vanished and exhaustion
hath departed
for i was exceedingly anxious to see
your kingdom the witch
may our lord establish
and after they had enjoyed food and
drink raban salma asked the king to be
allowed to see the churches
and the shrines of the fathers and the
relics of the saints that were therein
and the king handed raban salma over to
the nobles of his kingdom
and they showed him everything that was
there
[Music]
this video is sponsored by squarespace a
great choice if you want to increase
your online presence
as i'm sure you're aware squarespace are
great supporters of educational videos
and podcasts
and are the perfect thing to help you
set up a hub for whatever you want to
show off
whether it's history based general
business stuff or chickens
wearing people clothes it has a smooth
and easy to use interface
even i have been able to get my head
around with straightforward analytics
and blogging tools to pull everything
together head over to squarespace.com
for your free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
forward slash voices to get 10 off
thanks
[Music]
and when rabban sama went back to the
king he said
and now if the king will permit me i
will go
and fulfill the command of king argonne
for the command to me
was to enter the territory of the proge
and he departed from constantinople and
went down to the sea
and he embarked on a ship and came to
the middle thereof
where he saw a mountain from which smoke
ascended all day long
and in the night time fire showed itself
on it
and no man is able to approach the
neighborhood of it because of the stench
of sulphur
some people say that there is a great
serpent there
this sea is called the sea of italy now
it is a terrible sea
and very many thousands of people have
perished therein
and after two months of toil and
weariness and exhaustion
ravan salma arrived at the seashore and
he landed at the name of which
was napoli
the name of its king was irid shardarlo
and he went to the king and showed him
the reason why he had come
and the king welcomed him and paid him
honor now it happened that there was a
war
between him and another king whose name
was irid archon
and the troops of the one had come in
many ships and the troops of the other
were ready and they began to fight each
other and
irid archon conquered irid shardarlo
and slew 12 000 of his men and sunk
their ships
into the sea meanwhile raban sauma
and his companions sat upon the roof of
the mansion in which they lived
and they admired the way that the franks
waged war
for they attacked none of the people
except those
who were actually combatants
[Music]
and from that place they travelled
inland on horses
and they passed through towns and
villages and marveled because they found
no land which was destitute of buildings
on the road they heard that ma papa
was dead
[Music]
after some days they arrived in great
rome
[Music]
and robin salmer went to the church of
peter and paul
for the cell of the throne of mar papa
was situated therein
now after the death of marpappa twelve
men who were called
kaltunare administered the papal throne
and whilst they were taking counsel
together in order to appoint the new
pope raban salma sent a message to them
saying we are the ambassadors of king
argonne
and of the catholicus of the east and
the cardinal said
unto him for what purpose has thou come
hither
and said unto him the mongols and the
catholicus of the east have sent me
to ma papa concerning the matter of
jerusalem
and they have sent letters with me they
began to ask him questions saying
what is thy quarter of the world and why
hast thou come
and they said unto him where does the
catholicus live
where is the throne of the catholicus he
said to them
in baghdad and rabban salma said unto
them
know ye are our fathers that many of our
fathers have gone
into the countries of the mongols and
the turks and chinese and have taught
them
the gospel and at present time there are
many mongols
who are christians then the cardinals
summoned the amir of the city and
certain monks and commanded them to show
him the churches
and the holy places that were there and
they went forth straight away
and saw the places
[Music]
and then they went from that place to
the country of the tuscan and were
honorably entreated
and thence they went to jinno now the
latter country has no
king but the people thereof set up to
rule over it
some great man with whom they are
pleased
afterwards they went to the country of
paris to king
francis and the king sent out a large
company of men to meet them
and they brought them into the city with
great honor and ceremony
now the territories of the french king
were in extent more than a month's
journey and the king of france assigned
to rabin salma a place swearing to dwell
and three days later sent one of his
amirs to him and summoned him
to his presence
[Music]
he said unto him why hast thou come and
who sent thee
and rabban salma said unto him king
argon
and the catholicus of the east have sent
me concerning the matter of
jerusalem and the king of france
answered him
saying if it be indeed so that the
mongols
although they've been on christians are
going to fight against the arabs for the
capture
of jerusalem it is meat especially for
us that we should go
fight with them and if our lord willeth
go forth in full strength
and robin salmer said unto him now that
we have seen the glory of thy kingdom
and have looked upon the splendor of
your strength with the eyes of flesh
we ask you to command the men of the
city to show us the churches and the
shrines
and the relics of the saints and
everything else which is found with you
and is not to be seen in any other
country so that when we return we may
make known
in the various countries what we have
seen with you
and raban salma and his companions
remain for a month of days in this
great city of paris and they saw
everything that was in it
and they went forth from that place that
is to say from paris
to go to the king of england
to cassonia and having arrived in 20
days at their city
the inhabitants of the city went forth
to meet them and they asked them
who are you and raban salma and his
companions replied we are
ambassadors and we have come from beyond
the eastern seas
and we are envoys of the king and the
kings of the mongols
and the people made haste and went to
the king and informed him of their
arrival
and the king welcomed them gladly and
those who were with rabban salma
straight away gave to the king the
pukhdana of king argon
and the gifts which he had sent him and
the letter of ma catholicus
and king edward rejoiced greatly and he
was especially glad when raban salman
talked about the matter of jerusalem
and he said we the kings of these cities
bear upon
our bodies the signs of the cross and we
have no subject of thought
except this matter and my mind is
relieved on the subject about which i
have been thinking
when i hear that king argonne thinketh
as i think
and the king commanded rabban salma to
celebrate the eucharist
and he performed the glorious mysteries
and the king and his officers of state
stood up and the king partook of the
sacrament and made a great feast
that day then rabban salma said unto the
king
we beseech thee o king to give thy
servants in order to show us whatever
churches and shrines there are in this
country
so that when we go back to the children
of the east we may give them
descriptions of them
and the king replied thus shall ye say
to king argon and unto all of those in
the east
we have seen a thing that of which there
is nothing more wonderful
that is to say that in the countries of
the franks there are not
two confessions of faith but only one
namely that of jesus christ and all the
christians confess it
and king edward gave us many gifts and
money
for the expenses of the road
and robin salmer returned
he crossed the seas which he crossed
when he came and he arrived in
peace at the place where king argonne
was sound in body
and with the soul safely kept and he
gave to him the letter of blessings and
the gifts which he had brought from ma
papa
and from all the kings of the franks and
he showed
how all of them had welcomed him with
love and how they had hearkened gladly
to his pakhdane and he related the
wonderful things
which he had seen and the power of their
kingdoms
and the king rejoiced and was glad and
thanked him and said unto him
we have made thee to suffer great
fatigue
for thou art an old man in future we
shall not permit thee to leave us nay
we will set up a church at the gate of
our kingdom and thou shalt minister
therein and recite prayers
and these things took place in this way
[Music]
you